in speaking to you the first time
uh you certainly opened my eyes to what
was right in front of me and i wasn't
seeing it which was the implication
of
so many people who had never been
exposed to this pathogen who weren't
vulnerable to it right that they had a
completely effective response on board
now it does leave me with the next
question
which is
whatever that innate immunity is why
does it decay so rapidly in life
right i i know a lot about senescence
this surprises me very quickly in the
innate immunity why does it decay well i
know why it decays i don't understand
why it decays so precipitously
well i i'm not sure that this true
provided the innate immunity gets
strained right you know this is
something which has been pretty well
described essentially over the last 10
years that through epigenetic changes
you get it's not a classical memory
where you have a memory marker
but the epigenetic changes
will lead to a kind of functional
reprogramming of cells so that when they
produce the antibodies next time around
they will you know better recognize the
pathogen okay so then what you're
telling me
i think i get it but i don't know it so
uh
help me out here
a five-year-old
has pretty good innate immunity to covid
because their system has not been
programmed too very much because it has
not encountered very much the more of
that system that you narrow into some
into responding to some pathogen that
the child encounters the less of it is
available for general use is that what's
going on that this is a trade-off as you
get specific you lose the general yeah
yes
i mean it's it's taking a few shortcuts
but i mean that is certainly the way to
explain it to the audience okay
to me and in fact
that would not at all be a problem
if the narrow targeting which has high
specificity for example in form of you
know uh
adaptive antibodies right if it was
targeted at covet but it's not right so
i get this now so basically the point is
you've got some beautiful system that
could in principle see anything and it
will see a bunch of things and the point
is it can't do that forever and so
that and i never understood this before
and this has been a key feature this has
been one of the things that people don't
understand about your model and i'm not
saying that i understand whether your
model is right or wrong but when people
talk when sophisticated people talk
about garrett vandenbosch and his view
they say why is he so focused on the
innate immunity and these peculiarities
of it
and um
i think this is a pretty satisfying
answer right
the effectiveness of an untrained immune
system against covid is shockingly good
yes but the only limitation is is
because of the affinity of these
antibodies is lower yeah they interact
what they recognize in fact
are patterns
on the surface of the virus on the
surface of the cells patterns
and that is the beauty of this system
that the patterns these
most likely glycan patterns are shared
amongst a broad spectrum of different
viruses not only all the variants of
sarsko v2 but all the coronaviruses
most likely all the glycosylated
envelope viruses like even influenza etc
but because they bind through
multivalent binding their affinity
because in that case you talk about
avidity of the antibody responses
so they have the strength of binding is
you know
inferior to the strength of binding of
specific antibodies so you could say
well we do this all the time when we
vaccinate our childhood vaccinations for
example but you know there is no problem
as you were pointing out if the specific
antibodies that you use do a perfect job
because they have memory they have
strong affinity that means they will
strongly neutralize the innate
antibodies they are perfect but they
cannot cope with a high viral load
but if you break through that innate
immunity you will have the phenomenon
that we were just describing you will
get acquired antibodies and guess what
these acquired antibodies will be a
perfect match to the virus that cause
the disease
whereas now we are with wuhan
the spike it's not at all a good fit uh
obviously right to the virus we are
so you see how powerful this natural
immunity is the different components and
you know that's why i'm saying to your
point
you know i'm always saying i'm not a top
virologist or immunologist or a top
vaccinologist but you know it's so
multi-disciplinary i've learned to bring
these fields together even by physics if
you don't understand the difference
between a polyvalent igm binding you
know antibody and a specific igm for a
specific antigen you know you will never
ever understand this right so so it's so
many different uh aspects that need to
be con to be put into consideration and
i'm always saying
my the value i'm adding i hope i guess
is putting the different pieces of the
puzzle that i find in publications etc
to put them together and obviously you
know today's science is no longer
capable that's why i i loved the thing
you were saying at the better way
congress we need to rebuild the science
and to some extent for these complex
problems i think we need to also have a
different approach to science in a sense
that no thinking in silos but a
multi-disciplinary approach well here's
the funny thing i mean i agree with what
you said entirely and i'm
frustrated to no end that the way
scientific education has evolved has
caused this obsession with
specialization yeah and right and
technologies right technology and
specialization and no doubt these things
have their place but the problem is
synthesis is the natural partner of
reductionism right and it is not
rewarded in our system so what you're
saying well i'm not a you know a great
this a great that but what i can do is
bring the things together well to me
all of my favorite evolutionary
biologists were involved in synthesis
that's what they were doing is taking
all of these
isolated things that don't seem to tell
a story and figuring out where you have
to stand in order to say ah
that's what this is right you know and
and that's really
um it's such a it's such a crucial part
of the process and what we've
effectively been watching i mean if we
give the benefit of the doubt and we say
well okay
they really screwed this up but it was
an honest error well if it was an honest
error it was an honest error created by
a committee of specialists where nobody
remembers how to put the whole thing
together right absolutely and it's a
it's it's tragic and it's tragic at the
level of like a million american deaths
you know it's it's yeah unbelievable
yeah i i fully agree with you uh you
know it's it's it's just unbelievable
that in you know in
2022
where we have access to all these signs
all these technologies you know all
these you know institutes put like
millions of of of taxpayer dollars into
it and we are not we are not we have no
clue how to tackle you know uh a complex
health problem so that also means we
cannot give anything back to society
from all the the money that that got
invested right so all these publications
is in fact you know
they are essential they are important
but when you start to have publications
you know if it becomes
an objective in its own right
i've learned to use science as a tool
and if i don't see
any added value to the kind of problem
i'm studying i will not
dig very deep but if i think you know
even a molecular detail this could bring
a piece of the puzzle then i will take a
deep dive right and so it's a completely
different approach to you know to to to
science but you know you see it's needed
in situations like this
the public health authorities even the
key opinion leaders they don't know
what's happening right now will you do
you agree they have no clue where this
thing is going right they
it's like the worst of all possible
worlds they don't know what's going on
and they have no idea a that they're in
the dark and b that there's another way
that wouldn't leave them in the dark
right
we've just lost the understanding of
this and everybody who does it all of
the generalists are driven out because
frankly you can't compete as a
generalist inside of the system so yes
it's a tragedy and when you think about
the immense costs of this i mean and
they're not even all quantifiable you
know this week at this conference
the one that's uh
i'm reminded
i'm reminded of how
frightening this is but
the gaslighting of the vaccine injured
i cannot think of anything more
diabolical in this right you injure
people
and then you tell them it's in their
head yeah
right and then you tell other people
that they're part of an anti-vaxx
movement you know we are living in a
surrealistic world right now it's uh
nothing nothing makes sense anymore of
any you know this is yeah yeah i'm
always saying you know it's uh
it makes me and it takes something to
make me speechless but that that makes
me speechless right yeah i i find myself
also at a loss for words pretty
frequently
[Music]
you